va a ser al asad ha revalidado un cuarto
mandato de siete años en unas elecciones
en las que ya se anunciaba su victoria
antes de darse a conocer los resultados
al asad ha reforzado su poder en siria
pero ha perdido legitimidad de cara a la
comunidad internacional que no reconoce
estos comicios porque no cumplen con las
expectativas de la resolución 2255 del
consejo de seguridad que sienta las
bases de una nueva constitución y de
unas elecciones libres bajo supervisión
de observadores internacionales al asad
se enfrenta a un país devastado por 10
años de guerra y profundamente dividido
rusia y eran son sus principales aliados
en la guerra pero a la hora de la
reconstrucción siria necesita cientos de
miles de millones de dólares que vendrán
a través de las ayudas internacionales y
para poder ayudar a siria la comunidad
internacional necesita confiar en el
presidente asad que no ha dado muestras
de querer abrir el país a un proceso
democrático
sin garantías de volver los 5 millones
de refugiados que están en países como
el líbano no podrán regresar a siria